welcome to cloud on air
live webinars with google cloud we are
hosting webinars every tuesday
my name is manvinder singh i'm part of
the google cloud team and with me is
alim karim from netapp
and we're going to be talking about
netapp cloud volumes for gcp
a new storage service that you can use
with your tcp workloads
so before we get started just a reminder
you can ask questions
at any point of time i just use the
platform and we have
we have colleagues standing by to help
you answer those questions
uh all right so let's get started
so some of you may have seen last month
month we announced our strategic
partnership with netapp
and we announced that we're
collaborating to launch netapp cloud
volumes for gcp
this is a new storage service it's a
high performance storage service that
that
that offers multiple protocols it offers
nfs smb
uh and if you're using to use gcp for
your workloads
you can use this storage service while
taking advantage of
various advanced management features
like data synchronization and snapshots
and cloning
with your workloads and in today's
today's session we'll talk about
more talk more about what this service
is when to use it what kind of use cases
and and how to use the service as well
so just to talk quickly about the agenda
uh we'll start by talking about
when to use netapp cloud volumes uh
we'll talk about the architecture and
what kind of use cases you can use this
for
and also talk about when it's going to
be available in which regions and so
forth
and then finally we'll end with live q a
with that with that said let's get
started um alim so
talk to us about when can you use cloud
volumes what kind of use cases yeah
so when we when we initially before we
designed and developed cloud volumes we
spent a lot of time
talking to customers and really
understanding the context of filed and
unstructured workloads as it related to
public cloud
and when we looked at the data after all
of that analysis we found that you know
you could group these problems into
three main areas
right and three main areas and three
main personas so first as
you know sort of the slide shows is you
have a set of application owners and
application administrators
that are trying to migrate existing
applications from on premise to the
cloud
right and these applications are built
around requiring posix file services and
it's very difficult to re-architect them
so
the easiest way is usually to take them
as they are with minimal
architecture and move them to the cloud
and the reasons behind these vary
right perhaps the customer is moving out
of a physical data center
perhaps they're trying to map the
application that has a variable business
process and they want to take advantage
of the elasticity of the cloud to do it
so
the use case is actually very behind the
y on the migrate side
the second is a set of you know
developers and devops folks that are
trying to build
new applications in the cloud that
require shared file semantics
and a quick example of this right is you
know you're trying to set up a
kubernetes cluster that could have
thousands of containers in it and all of
those containers require access
to a shared file system right so that's
another big use case that we're seeing
and then finally we have you know data
analysts data engineers that have
a lot of unstructured data on premise
that they want to take to google cloud
to take advantage of the advanced
machine learning and analytics
capabilities that the cloud offers
to be able to get value out of that
unstructured data so those are the three
broad
use cases now common amongst these use
cases on the right hand side is really
the expectation so all of these personas
really have
three main expectations around any
service that satisfies these problems
the first is this notion of experience
and experience is not just about
performance and scalability
it's also about how well the service is
really integrated into gcp
and integrated not just from control
plane but also from a support and
billing perspective
the other two pieces around consumption
and economics really go hand in hand
right so being a true cloud service
customers expect this to be able to ramp
up their consumption
and the economics of that go up with
consumption and as the consumption comes
down their economics goes
down right and then the final piece is
you know within any cloud context the
ability to have a high degree of
security
and compliance as part of the service
so now let's talk about cloud volumes
for google what they
are and the various elements that that
go with them so the simplest way to
think about cloud volumes is they
that they are a no ops managed service
they offer our customers
a simple to consume performant nfs
or smb endpoint and all the customer has
to do is consume that
endpoint without having to worry about
any of the infrastructure pieces
that are behind the scenes to operate
that that's you know between netapp and
google to to handle that
so there's really no need to manage
patch
scale maintain do any of the
infrastructure related tasks
you know there's many there's three
different service levels that we offer
cloud volumes on and the next slide will
go into some of those details
but each of those service levels is
really just a simple nfs or smb endpoint
in a no ops fashion the second element
is really around
native user experience so when customers
go and provision
manage and monitor cloud volumes they
actually get
an interface and you know a user
interface that is
identical to how they would provision
any other google service
so i just want to stress upon that point
because when customers use
partner services on gcp they're not used
to actually using the same interface
so this would look and feel just like a
google service exactly and really what
we wanted to focus on here is keeping
that customer experience
seamless keeping them within the google
ecosystem
and therefore you know they don't have
to learn other interfaces and then just
use what they're used to
the next point around rich data
management this is where netapp brings
its years of capabilities around being
able to rapidly create snapshots
clones and be able to synchronize data
for all of the data that lives in cloud
volumes
support is another area that we hear
from customers about right in in that
to complete that customer life cycle the
ability to have integrated support is
very very important so with cloud
volumes l1 support is actually managed
by the google cloud team
with similar slos as other gcp services
on the right hand side around pay as you
go and billing right so again being
a cloud service you only pay for the
amount of capacity you provision
and that provision capacity can vary
over the course of a day
over the course of a week over the
course of a month and you just pay
for the average consumption over the
course of a month
with that is the notion of integrated
billing right so even though this is a
netapp service
it's very deeply integrated with google
so you as a customer get your bill from
google
just as part of your regular gcp invoice
with the consumption of cloud volumes as
a single line item
on that bill hybrid enabled right so i
talked a lot about
customers being able to move data
between on-premise and the cloud so
we're offering services
to be able to sync data from on-prem is
making it easier for customers
to move to cloud volumes in gcp and then
finally we have a plan to roll out this
service across the globe
starting with you know some regions in
the us and expanding out as we go
so all these points taken together alim
uh with the native user experience with
integrated support with billing being
integrated
as a user i may not even have to talk to
netapp or interface with netapp while
consuming the service right
absolutely right and this is again to
the earlier point that we were making is
we want customers to stay within the gcp
ecosystem
and reduce the friction that it takes to
consume this service amazing
cool
now let's talk about service levels so
cloud volumes are really available
in let's call it three different flavors
right and these flavors are identical in
the sense that you can offer
or you can consume both nfs and smb
protocols across any service level
you get the advanced data management
features across all service levels and
the ability to take snapshots
do rapid copies do cloning or do data
synchronization
but what's different with these service
levels is the amount of throughput that
you get
per terabyte of capacity that you
provision right so we have
standard we have premium we have extreme
standard offers customers 16 megabytes
per terabyte provisioned
premium is 64 megabytes per terabyte and
then extreme
is double that at 128 megabytes per
terabyte there are three different price
points to go along with these three
different service levels
and really why we have these three
flavors as the use cases indicate right
we intend customers to be able to use
different service levels
for different kinds of workloads right
so in the case of standard
they're likely going to use things like
file backup or web serving
in the case of premium they're going to
use it for virtualized applications
potentially general purpose databases
and then on the extreme side really it's
where
you know use cases like high performance
computing and oltp come into play
on on high performance computing you
know that can there can be so many
different use cases across
across particles there's eda uh is is
there's
financial we have a lot of hedge funds
who want to do monte carlo simulations
for example
and one nfs endpoints to store the data
there's genomic sequencing
sequencing is that all of those use
cases do they fit under the extreme tier
yeah yeah exactly because those are all
typically you find areas that require
high throughput
sometimes high number of iops and very
very low latency right so those are
good fits for the extreme tier and if i
start with the extreme tier and you know
i i see that the performance is is
already very good for for my use case
and i may want a lower priced option can
i move to the premium tier
that's right you can dynamically move to
the premium tier awesome
so let's say you know you're a customer
and you're trying you you want to
consume the cloud volume service so what
does the technical architecture
underneath it look like
so here we have a simple diagram that
shows a standard
google customer project on the left hand
side in this project we have gce
instances that have been provisioned in
the u.s east 4 region
note that these instances could be any
in any zone in u.s
east 4 and they're in within a given vpc
on the right hand side is where you have
the cloud volume service and in this
case
the user has used that interface to
provision three cloud volumes
so on the top part you you'll notice a
dotted line
and so there's a subscription element
between the customers project and the
cloud volume service
because each cloud volume only exists
within the context of a google project
just like any other google resource
within a project
on the bottom part for each cloud volume
we expose an export path
which is then used by the instances to
mount that volume and access the data in
that volume
a few things to note here cloud volumes
in this case are accessible to
any instance in any zone within a given
region that's number one
number two is with the use of export
policies
you can really actually restrict which
instances are able to see the data in
cloud volumes
you can restrict it by a single ip
address for a single client
you can restrict it to an ip range and
you can even tune your export policies
so that you can allow certain clients to
read and write
while other clients can only read data
in cloud volumes
so now let's talk through a few use
cases and what we've seen
you know with early customers that are
that are using cloud volumes
so the first one is around continuous
integration and a software development
environment
so we have a customer who has an
automated ci environment
that essentially deploys a cluster with
over a thousand different containers
that come up in that cluster
and all of those containers require
access to a shared file system
to hold all the binaries that the
containers are going to use for their
build jobs as well as the output to
build artifacts once the jobs are
complete
right so again a great use case for
cloud volumes because you get that
shared file service
but the other key thing to note here is
the kpis in this environment
are the amount of unit tests that these
customers can do in a given hour
and that is directly correlated with the
amount of time it takes to do a build
right so it's not just about being able
to provide a shared file system
but being able to provide a shared file
system that is high performance so
they need high throughput they need low
latency to be able to keep those build
times
to the minimum and do more unit tests
within a given
period of time
the next use cases are on video
rendering and this is one of those
classic use cases with media processing
workflows rendering
transcoding both from a product
production and post-production sense
that have tools that are built around
shared file system and the access
pattern here is actually very different
from the earlier use case we talked
about here
access is very serial it is still high
performant but it requires also again
very very low latency this is this is
another good use case we see for cloud
volumes
that matches the tools that are built
for this use case with the performance
that cloud volumes deliver
so earlier manvinder you touched on high
performance computing
and eda so i'm going to use the eda
example here and
eda you know is a complicated
environment on its own you have various
phases around
specification block design and
verification synthesis
formal verification and simulation and
each of these phases has different
tools but and requires different file
access patterns
but this is an example of you know
workloads that have
for years relied on file services so you
have applications and tools
that are designed with the need for file
services and these tools specific
protocols like nfs
exactly and these tools are not going to
get re-architected
right they are going to exist as they
are it's just you know too hard to
rebuild these tools
and so when you have you know front-end
design systems
in this eda space that resemble software
r d they're code heavy
they use verilog they use vhdl and to
your point
these are tools that again are very
tightly integrated with
or require nfs right
and the kpi around here again
performance is of the essence
the ability to complete these workflows
in time so this requires
you know cloud volume specifically to be
able to handle large volumes of small
files at very very low latency
especially especially during the
verification stage
the final use cases around databases
right and we have customers that are
using mysql databases and this could be
you know this is
could be other databases as well for
transactional web platforms and they've
built an application that actually
requires scale-up performance
but the other unique thing around this
or not just around performance is
you know this customer or this set of
customers actually needs the ability to
take
consistent point-in-time reference
copies of their database for recovery
purposes
and again the ability to do this while
not impacting user experience
still providing those high iops and hot
and low latency on a shared file system
are key for this this particular
customer so another great use case for
cloud volumes
awesome that's a lot of use cases yeah
so let's talk about timelines where we
are today and and where we're going to
go with cloud volumes in the future
so currently the service is available in
private preview
we've been running the private preview
since early may since about when we
announced the partnership
and we have a few customers that are
trying cloud volumes are really happy
with it that's right
and we have we're offering this out of
the gcp us east 4 region
for those of you that are watching and
are interested in participating in the
preview and expressing your interest for
cloud volumes
please go to the link that's on the
slide netapp.com forward slash gcp
preview
and register there in terms of future
you know the next phases for the service
are really taking it to control the
availability and general availability
so we're going to be making some
announcements around the google next
time frame
as well as discussing which regions the
service rolls out to
so i encourage all of you please visit
us at the netapp booth at next
connect with our smes and get some
hands-on demos at the booth as well cool
so to quickly summarize cloud volumes
for gcp basically are simple to consume
no ops nfs or smb services they offer
our customers high performance and rich
data management
features and are very tightly integrated
into gcp along different dimensions on
the user interface and control plane
side
with support and with billing and
ultimately cloud volumes for google
allow our customers to migrate existing
workloads to gcp they allow our
customers to develop
new applications on gcp that require
performant file storage
and finally allow our customers to take
advantage of the best in class analytics
and machine learning capabilities that
google offers on unstructured data
awesome thank you ali all right folks
stay tuned for live q a
we'll be back in less than a minute
okay uh so we've got some great
questions here uh i'm gonna go a little
bit out of water alim sure just to touch
upon the
stuff we just talked about um so we
talked about uh
how a lot of the features that customers
are used to on premise uh
with netapp in many cases uh are now
available in the cloud
uh but a question that we're getting a
lot from from our audience is uh how do
i get that data into cloud volumes
i may have it in that app or in a
different platform how do i move that
data yeah so we're actually going to
use our cloud sync tool to be able to
allow customers to move data from
on-premise
into cloud volumes as well as between
cloud volumes
and we can expect that it's not
available now but it'll be a roadmap
item that we add around the ga time
frame
great and that that's uh moving data
over the network right that's correct
yeah that's that's an over the wire
and it doesn't have to be netapp on
premise it can be yeah and then this
this is the you know the great thing
about a tool like cloud sync right it
can work with any unstructured file
format right
it could be netapp storage it could be
other storage it basically as long as
that storage exposes an nfs
endpoint or smb endpoint we're able to
then migrate that data
into cloud volumes any limit on the
amount of data i want to move terabytes
hundreds of terabytes
yeah so this is where again it's a use
case dependent uh question right like if
you have small amounts of data and you
have good network throughput you're able
to move that right
or using tools like cloud sync what we
call over-the-wire synchronization tools
but as you get into larger bulk data
sets we're actually exploring
partnering with google on being able to
move bulk data in an offline fashion
right so more of
a bulk data move and then followed by a
sink to get
you know basically hundreds of terabytes
into gcp into cloud volumes
okay cool awesome uh so uh talking about
the protocols that the service is going
to support
nfs there are multiple versions v3 v4
what's
what's the thinking on that front so
initially we're going to support nfs v3
and smb v3 and i think that kind of
answers a couple of those questions
we're going to add smb sorry nfs v4
support down the
road and this is also an area where we
really want to hear from our customers
right on what kind of protocols they
want to use we're hearing a lot of
demand for smd v3 and nfs v3 which is
why we're starting
that's where bulk of the applications
yeah what they use right yeah i think
based on some of the analysis we did
about 80
of the workloads that are nfs based use
nfs v3
so that seemed like a logical place to
go uh but again we're we're open to
feedback and hearing from customers on
use cases around nfs v4 and what they
want to do
great fantastic is the cloud volume uh
accessible from multiple gcp projects ah
so that we touched a little bit on this
presentation but this is a good question
to bring up
so much like any other gcp resource
within a project
this is a a project level resource so
cloud volume
exists and is accessible only within the
context of a project
right so if you have multiple projects
cloud volume in one project
is only accessible to that project cloud
volumes in another project only
accessible to that other project
right there's no sharing of cloud
volumes between projects
okay great all right what regions is the
service available in
yeah so regions wise we're currently
offering private preview in u.s east 4
however we're going to be rolling out to
other regions in the u.s the timeline
for that is when we will talk about
during the next announcements
in terms of which regions are coming up
and when one of the things i want to add
to that is
if you have workloads that you want to
move to gcp and you have specific
regions in mind
uh please do give us the feedback you
could use the link that we shared
earlier for signing up for the private
preview and
that way we'll connect with you and we'd
love to hear which regions are a
priority for you
so we can we can work on those and
prioritize those accordingly
uh thank you for tuning in everyone uh
that's that's all we had for
this session uh please do stay tuned in
for the next session
which is on connected healthcare and how
to enable secure entry points into the
cloud with chrome
thank you
you